x
de touristes.
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
- On visite les Îles pour
se ressourcer, se dépayser et
profiter d'un cadre idyllique.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais chaque jour, c'est aussi
près d'une demi-douzaine de
spectacles qui sont à l'affiche.
Des vedettes qui ne se font pas
prier pour venir se produire
dans ce paysage de carte
postale.
PATRICE MICHAUD,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Moi, je peux péter
te crise de princesse
si je viens pas aux Îles
sur une tournée, puis
plus qu'une fois, si possible.
- Des stars du continent qui
côtoient des vedettes des Îles,
comme Tante Emma...
- "Du là", "est ba là",
"qu'est-ce que tu fais","cosse .
- ... qui a vendu plus
de 100 000 billets pour
son spectacle, qu'elle présente
depuis 20 ans.
ODETTE LEBLANC,
alias TANTE EMMA, comédienne
- J'interprète la carte
des îles à la manière d'une
Madelinienne, d'un Madelinot Mat
pour les faire découvrir qui
est-ce qu'on est, nous, les gens
en dedans, les particularités
des villages, les accents.
♪ ♪
- Que ce soit pour tourner
des films...
♪ ♪ ♪
... des émissions télé
idéoclips,
les Îles ont la cote.
KLOÉ JIANGZHU ARSENEAU, prod. et
technicienne sur des tournages
- C'est énorme, on a des
demandesdemandesdemandesdemandee
si je pourrai pas toutes
accepter. T'sais, c'est vraiment
beaucoup, beaucoup de demandes
et ça a vraiment fait un grosbo.
- Un bouillonnement qu'on
constate également au
populaire bar spectacles
Les Pas Perdus.
STÉPHANE LAPIERRE, dir.
programmation, Les Pas Perdus
- On voyait quand même avant
la pandémie qu'on était pour
avoir des problèmes de staff,
d'employés. C'était toujours
des records. On va dire ça
de même, un peu des records :
"Ah, c'est encore une plus
grosse soirée, une plus grosse
soirée, plus de grosses soirées
dans l'année."
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et malgré l'abondance
de l'offre, le public
est au rendez-vous et
les artistes en redemandent.
DJ CHAMPION, disque-jockey
- T'arrives ici, il y a
un esprit musical,
C'est clair, là. Les gens
mangent la musique.
- Une offre culturelle
foisonnante qui fait plaisir
aux Madelinots.
- L'affaire, c'est que quand
il y a une offre trop grande,
c'est que tu sais pu quoi
choisir, tu découvres pas tout,
tu vois
- Mais aussi un raz-de-marée
de touristes qui entraînent
dans leur sillage son lot
d'irritants.
as oublieras oublieras oubliera,
c'est quand même une
collectivité, il y a du monde
qui vit ici à l'année, puis
on n'est pas un "resort" ici.
- Des craintes don
bien conscients les acteurs
économiques locaux qui
scrutent l'horizon.
ANTONIN VALIQUETTE, DG, Chambre
de commerce, Îles-de-la-Madel.
- Ça fait plusis,s,s,s,s,s,
je dirais depuis 2014, 2015
environ, que le nombre de
visiteurs ait plafonné.
On estime en fait qu'au maximum
il y a à peu près un visiteur,
un tourisident
madelinot en même temps
sur les Îles-de-la-Madeleine.
- Par contre, la saison
touristique s'allonge et
ces vagues de touristessur des t
que 12 000 habitants est
un réel défi dans un contexte
de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
et de logement.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Tout le monde ici vous le dira
aux Îles : il y a des musiciens
dans chaque famille.
C'est ce qui a plu au musicien
et copropriétaire du Vent
du Large qui a mis le cap sur
les Îles il y a près de 10 ans.
FRANÇOIS GUAY, musicien,
copropriétaire, Vent du Large
- On a été très, très bienaccuee
que ça aidait d'avoir un violon
dans les mains. Ça, ça a été
un passeport dès notre arrivée
à Isabelle et à moi ici.♪
- C'est cette culture forte
qui a également incité
le chansonnier Claude Cormier
à revenir accoster sur son île
et à y jeter l'ancre.
Deux soirs par semaine,
il présente une boîte à chansons
où il partage la scène avec
tés.
CLAUDE CORMIER, chansonnier
- Il y a du monde qui nous ont
précédé. Aujourd'hui, on porte
le flambeau et ceux qui s'en
, c'est un talent brut,
c'est incroyable. Les jeunes
sont talentueux. La culture
des Îles, la musique des Îles
est pas prête de disparaître.-Î-
Madeleine est maintenant de
naviguer entre les ambitions
touristiques et la volonté
de conserver un milieu de vie
pour les  pour les  pour les  s
qui y habitent à l'année.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Havre Aubert,
aux Îles-de-la-Madelein